[Music]  this is a safe place  i'm agoraphobic i can't  go inside i've been sleeping getting  into a really  dark frame of mind  so what's the latest on the street your  neighbor  she's become a friend her name is jane  russell  do you want to go outside you know i  have a shrimp  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  protect the little nypd where's jane mr  wrestle believes that you made a mistake  you have never met my wife  ma'am you all right i know jane jane's  been in my house  i'm jane russell i'm not crazy  i know what i saw they're all hiding  something  you will not never have my mother  stop watching our house your doctor said  that your  meds can cause hallucinations  i'm not hallucinating  [Music]  i think there is somebody in my house  don't go looking into other people's  houses  you won't like what you see  [Music]  [Music]  you